if you don't know turn into the
microcosmos has its own micro Cosmos
microscope a microscope that we designed
specifically for people who are new to
the Hobby of microscopy who maybe want
to discover their very first tardigrade
it's a really wonderful moment I had
mine about two and a half years ago and
with the macro Cosmos microscope you are
able to attach your phone to it so you
can take pictures and video of the
things that you discover when I first
wanted to try out microscopy I found the
step of finding the right microscope to
start with a very intimidating so we're
just trying to make that easier for
everybody you can find it and a bunch of
other stuff like great shirts and socks
to celebrate the microscopic world
around us at microcosmos.store
[Music]
if you need to nominate an ambassador to
represent the microcosmos you have to go
with the tardigrade they are weird
adorable and very Hardy a combination of
traits that has made them many people's
first entry point into the microscopic
world and no matter how much time you
spend with them tardigrades will find
new ways to surprise you in fact when
we've looked back on our journey through
the microcosmos and our encounters with
tardigrades we've noticed that many of
those streamed sightings involve
something that does not immediately come
to mind when you think about tardigrades
sex
so today we wanted to thread together
these Tales of tardigrade mating and not
just because it's fun but also because
there's a lot to learn from
understanding how tardigrades make more
of themselves let's start with one of
our early videos about tardigrades where
we introduced a pregnant water bear
whose eggs were beginning to develop
even as her body remained still and
whose fate we will get to see play out
later in this compilation
foreign
we don't know about you but here on the
micro Cosmos team we find it hard not to
smile as we watch tardigrades with their
cute pitch black eyes and little feet
ambling across the smooth glass surface
of the microscope slide Moss piglets
water bears whatever you call them
they're fascinating to watch and even
more fascinating to try and understand
they are a puzzle and we humans are The
Puzzler
[Music]
and so we figured
sure we've already focused on
tardigrades in a previous episode but we
cannot possibly leave it there after all
like the microscopic world around them
tardigrades always have more to show us
our water bears are collected from ponds
and growing Moss environments that give
them the water and food they need to
thrive and so behind the scenes we like
to give them a bit of attention making
sure that they are well fed and
comfortable in their slides after all a
drop of water is barely anything to us
but to a tardigrade a thing so tiny and
so good at surviving that drop can be
everything
tardigrades of course live their lives
absent of any kind of intention to teach
us anything they don't even know we're
here but watching is a form of
interaction and one that reveals the
interface between the micro the macro
and even the cosmic so let's start with
a part of the tardigrade body whose
weirdness we haven't had the chance to
fully appreciate here yet
their mouths the opening of the
tardigrade mouth is a distinct ring
giving way to a tube that connects to
the pharyngeal bulb which helps the
tardigrade suction out the juicy
contents of its meals but to get to the
juice the tardigrade first needs to
pierce its Target relying on a pair of
stylets that poke out of the mouth ring
when it comes time to feed when the
tardigrade molts they shed their stylets
and replace them with a new pair
tardigrades are omnivorous they're open
to eating bacteria plants and animals
for some species their meal might even
be another tardigrade but for the
species here our samples contain plenty
of algae and plant matter for them to
dine on collected from the same watery
and earthy worlds as the tardigrades
these bits of organic matter keep them
well fed like a built-in Buffet but
there are other times where bearing
witness to the microcosmos takes a
little more adaptation on our part
recently we found a water bear with its
half shed cuticle filled with eggs
still attached to its body in what
amounts to
Parenting in the micro Cosmos as you
might imagine we were more than a little
curious to watch these eggs develop
but if you keep a slide on a microscope
for too long the water will evaporate
taking with it the moisture the
tardigrade needs to exist outside of its
desiccated dormant state so we kept
these slides in humidity Chambers and
took Extra Care to make sure the cover
slip wouldn't crush the developing
tardigrades and then
we watched
the tardigrade though was still
this video is from our sixth day of
observation the only sign of life
being the absence of decomposition
[Music]
three days later we can see the eggs are
developing and there are even little
tardigrade heads appearing the mother
still seems the same attached to her
eggs and seemingly still alive despite
her complete Stillness
when it comes time to hatch the embryos
will use their stylets and pharyngeal
pump to make their way out sucking in
water to increase the pressure on the
egg from the inside until the shell
breaks but
still waiting for that day to come with
this tardigrade brood embryonic
development in tardigrade can last from
five days to more than 100 varying by
species and dependent on environmental
factors like temperature
the thing with Biology no matter what
scale of creature you're looking at is
that you are always on their schedule
not the other way around
[Music]
food and birth probably seem a bit
domestic compared to some of the more
recent tardigrady and exploits you may
have heard about earlier in 2019 Israel
sent a spacecraft called bearishite To
The Moon taking with it among many
things a digital Archive of almost the
entirety of English Wikipedia and also
thousands of tardigrades dried out in
their ball-like ton form and ready for
liftoff
seconds before a bearishite was supposed
to land however it lost contact with
mission control and crashed instead
leaving one very obvious question what
will happen to those thousands of
tardigrades potentially spilled across
the surface of the Moon
our seeming penchanted for sending
tardigrades into space has taught us
that they are able to tolerate vacuums
without liquid water of course the
tardigrades will remain in their dormant
State maybe if someone is able to return
to that crash site decades from now they
might manage to find tardigrades that
survived that crash and there's a chance
that with a little water
they could come back to life
still working to understand all of the
tricks of tardigrade Survival how does
it play out in their DNA and proteins
and why some tardigrade species seem to
be better than others
this is part of the fun of tardigrades
and our Collective fascination with them
we're all learning together here on
planet Earth like a giant science
classroom asking important questions
like is that round thing the mouth and
what does happen when you put a
tardigrade on the moon maybe this is our
21st century remix of Apollo a
conversation between microcosmos and
good old-fashioned Cosmos
science is ultimately a mix of
deliberate and accidental questions
taking on many forms to suit our
available tools
sometimes science is a detailed study
and sometimes it's a crash landing it
can be a collector of microbes and a
master of microscopes carefully tending
to samples to meet the need the needs of
their invisible residents and sometimes
it's you watching along making your own
observations and maybe even thinking of
new questions that no one has ever
thought to ask before
thank you
in our next video we're jumping straight
to the point this is a video about
tardigrade sex featuring you know
tardigrades having sex and the process
is about as perplexing to watch as you
might imagine tardigrade mating would be
welcome to season two of The Journey to
the micro Cosmos and we are starting
things off with a pun very much intended
a bang or more accurately a multitude of
bangs and we should warn you it gets
weird there's poop there's molted skin
there's the inexhaustible Spirit of the
tardigrade in flagrante
South how did we get here well sex
obviously if we're talking in the grand
biological scheme of things it is for
some an evolutionarily advantageous way
of making Offspring but we're talking
about tardigrade sex right now in part
because of a pregnant water bear that we
started tracking in an episode last
season even though the mother-to-be was
completely motionless we were able to
see the heads of baby tardigrades
forming in the eggs and we were excited
to record and share the moment of all
those Moss piglets hatching
unfortunately nature had different plans
and we'll talk about that more in our
next episode
but James our master of microbes has
been hard at work documenting the lives
of the tardigrades in his care and that
means not only have we been able to find
more tardigrades hatching we've seen
some particularly Vivid demonstrations
of the steps that came before these
hearty animals can reproduce asexually
via parthenogenesis but our recent
samples have been full of frisky water
bears and that is what we're going to
focus on today
sure tardigrades contain an immense
capacity for survival it astounds and
boggles the mind and it is a joy and a
privilege to share the biology and
visual wonders of their lives alongside
all of the other tiny organisms we talk
about but sometimes what the job asks
for maybe even demands is that we film
nature as it occurs this is not what
James expected when he ventured out to a
river to collect some mud even when it
turned out that he had hit a microbial
jackpot and counted at least 15
tardigrades on the first slide he
prepared from the sample but as he
continued to watch
he saw these two smaller tardigrades
both mysteriously drawn to the
underbelly of a larger one they seemed
to be trying to reach into the belly
with their piercing mouths but the whys
and the hows and the Whos were all
unclear their goal was mysterious and
besides tardigrades rarely demonstrate
such a focused interest on much of
anything
but 20 minutes later those two jabbers
were still at it
their determination became much more
understandable when the eggs inside the
bigger tardigrade became visible marking
her as a female holding a number of
unfertilized eggs and marking the
smaller tardigrades as males vying to do
the Fertilization in a microscopic love
triangle or as we call it at the
microcosmos headquarters a menajah tuata
grade
[Music]
was that too much who knows so just how
focused are these male tardigrades well
remember that time we watched a solitary
tardigrade poop what a nice surprisingly
cute and relaxing clip that was well now
let's watch a large female tardigrade
defecate with apparently no care at all
for her suitors and watch those two
continue poking the water bear anyway
undaunted by The Cloud of poop around
them
but even tardigrades surrender
eventually and after 30 minutes of this
poking and prodding one of the males
made a graceful exit perhaps having lost
out on the mating battle with the path
clear the remaining male got a good hold
on the female's cuticle sticking with
her for a whole hour in their joint
Endeavor to fertilize her eggs
this couple was not the only one we
observed in action in fact this sample
was full of tardigrade's mating and the
behavior we observed was consistent
which is important scientifically
given the collective fascination with
tardigrades it might surprise you to
learn that their sex lives have not been
well documented perhaps the most
thorough study we were able to find is a
2016 paper that was conducted by
scientists at the schneckenberg Museum
of Natural History in gorlitz Germany it
was published in the Zoological Journal
of the linnaean society and their work
Chronicles the mating behavior of
isohipsibius dastic eye a different
species from the one we're observing
here but their work was still a helpful
basis from which to understand the
various Oddities and necessities of
water bear sex
the adulthood of tardigrades is often
defined by the number of molts it takes
for them to reach sexual maturity for
example the female idastic eye develops
eggs during her third molt but at this
stage the female doesn't shed off their
molted outside called the exuvia they
molt their cuticle but then they stay in
it like wearing your shed skin like a
coat and why not they stay in there
along with their eggs when male
tardigrades were added to the mix they
made a beeline for these egg-bearing
females in the exact technical terms
used by the scientists in the paper the
process starts with the male quote
bringing his cloaca close to the mouth
opening in the exuvia and thus begins a
process of quote Mutual stimulation
the female uses her stylets and sucking
pharynx to prod at the male's abdomen as
part of a mating process that will take
similar to our tardigrades about an hour
it all ends of course with ejaculation
but how that fertilization occurs can
vary in some species sperm might enter
through an opening in the exuvia and
others the male might use their stylists
to poke holes in the shed cuticle that
they then deposit their sperm into one
species has been seen using both of
those methods the observations that have
been documented are that challenging
combination of rare and different where
it's not clear how everything fits
together and in cases like the species
we're looking at right now that means
the mechanisms actually remain unclear
the sexual habits of the species are
undocumented this is science right here
you're watching it as for when and how
the sperm is deposited either we weren't
able to film the exact right moment or
it happened so subtly that we missed it
in short it's different for different
species and it's not well studied and
even though we had a slide full of risky
tardigrades it was still a challenge to
observe sometimes here at Journey to the
microcosmos we end our episodes talking
about how observing the microcosmos
gives us new and better perspectives on
the whole rest of the world
but sometimes we're just excited to have
the opportunity to see something so few
people have seen and that's just
interesting because it is and hopefully
this video will be part of a hopefully
ongoing tradition to record tardigrade
mating and next week we're going to be
back with the fruits of their labor to
show you the highs and the lows of
tardigrade birth
we're going to be returning to the fates
of the tardigrades in those first two
videos in a bit but before we do that we
wanted to digress a little bit we ended
that last video with the hope that we
would be part of a developing tradition
of recorded tardigrade mating
unnecessary step in developing our
understanding of how tardigrades
reproduce well a few years later we
returned to the tardigrade to learn more
about a much more established tradition
that is the tradition of people coming
up with strange theories about
tardigrade sperm
foreign
this is not an organism
it's not yet anyway what we are looking
at are a lot of zoo spores packed
together getting ready to be released so
that they can find the right place to
grow into themselves
and this well this is a male tardigrade
Filled from head to many toes with sperm
just chock full of it
[Music]
we did not start this Channel with the
intent of becoming so familiar with
tardigrade mating habits but tardigrades
are easy to find and their mating habits
are straightforward enough to track so
we keep getting drawn back into the
details and the drama of tardigrade
reproduction
in the past we've talked about the
particulars of their mating habits and
today we're going to use this tardigrade
as a convenient starting point to talk
about the history of our understanding
of sperm because as absurd as it might
seem to be looking at tardigrade sperm
the theories people have had about sperm
are much weirder
humans have been theorizing about the
contents of seminal fluid long before
the invention of the microscope we did
not as a species need to work out all of
the scientific mechanisms underlying
sexual reproduction to make babies but
the observation of children who carried
traits from their parents naturally
raised questions about how those traits
were passed on and those questions
inevitably led to some hypotheses and
look not all hypotheses need to be good
in fact many of them are terrible it's
just that when you're trying to
understand the world you need to start
somewhere and as long as you're willing
to work with your ideas and challenge
them then hopefully someday you go from
somewhere to somewhere better
some of these early ideas about sperm
weren't just bad though they were maybe
as we should expect a little
self-serving to the male ego
masturbatory even you could say like the
theory now known as spermism advocated
for by one Pythagoras yes that
Pythagoras according to spermism the
information driving heredity came
entirely through the semen whether that
was the color of someone's hair or their
height or whatever other trait all of
that came through the father and the
father's father and so on the mother's
role was just to provide nourishment to
the sperm as it developed and manifested
those traits it's easy enough to find
flaws with this idea after all our
observed reality which Pythagoras just
chose to ignore shows us that traits
pass from mother and father alike but
this would not be the last Theory to
overestimate the sperm even with the
advance of scientific tools over the
ages there was plenty to get wrong one
of those key scientific tools was of
course the microscope which allowed
scientists to observe the cells within
semen for the first time but just
because microscopists could see sperm
now that did not mean that they could
make out the details and this invited
speculation including the idea that we
are essentially developed from a much
smaller version of ourselves this theory
was called pre-formationism at the end
of the 17th century the Dutch scientist
and Nicolas Heart soccer sketched out
his spermist vision of pre-formationism
inside the head of the sperm cell he
speculated was a very very very small
human later called a homunculus just
waiting for a womb to grow in and look
we have the advantage of centuries of
advancements to know that the homunculus
was wrong but maybe take a moment to
just think about how weird that would be
if it were right look at this tardigrade
full of sperm and then just imagine if
we zoomed in further on those sperm
cells and we could see little tiny
tardigrades inside of them and then if
we could zoom in even more on those
tinier tardigrades we'd see even more
tinier tardigrades inside of them and so
on and so on now to be clear that is not
what tardigrade sperm looks like their
sperm is made up of a slightly globular
head connected to a flagellum but as
wrong as both spermism and tiny people
inside of sperm turned out to be they're
not that far off the Mark if you think
about the zoo aspores we showed at the
beginning of the episode they are a tool
of asexual reproduction and a lot of
different organisms including algae
fungi and bacteria they all use
zoospores in different ways and because
we don't know exactly what organism
these duosports come from there are
specific details of their lives we just
don't know but take for example the
phytophthora a group of oh oh my seeds
most notorious for their role in the
19th century potato blight that led to
the Great Famine in Ireland
phytophthora can reproduce sexually but
they mostly rely on making asexual
zoospores which pack together in a
biological enclosure called the
sporangia until the conditions are right
for their release and when they emerge
from the sporangia the zoo aspores start
swimming using their flagella and
chemical sensors to find the ideal place
to settle and germinate all of the
hereditary information in those
zoospores came from one parent
fashioning an organism that resembles
the infant form of that parent and that
seeks only nourishment from its new host
the outlines of that process sound
pretty similar to how early philosophers
and scientists envisioned their
sperm-centric ideas of sexual
reproduction but what those scientists
missed what separates the sperm from the
zoospore is the nature of sexual
reproduction itself of the genetic
variation it drives by combining and
recombining traits from different
parents
sperm cannot accomplish that on their
own
sperm need an ovum to fertilize which
scientists would eventually uncover in
the 19th century with experiments on
rabbits sea urchins and starfish eggs
that helped to further our understanding
of the molecular and cellular
collaboration that set the stage for
inheritance
yes my friends as Napoleon drove to
conquer Europe we had no idea that sperm
and eggs came together to make the Next
Generation
there are a lot of different types of
spores out there used both for sexual
and asexual reproduction and in contrast
sperm might seem more narrow and focused
both in diversity and in purpose but the
function of sperm is so specialized that
it requires its own diversity even among
tardigrades there are different
morphologies to the head and middle
structures of the sperm small
differences that distinguish between
species and that's because however weird
our theories about sperm have been the
reality is also very strange of all the
cells in the body sperm cells are maybe
the only ones that are expected to
navigate and survive in two different
beings the homunculus was wrong but the
idea of there being an image of our life
passed on within sperm and in spores it
isn't absurd at all it's just too
literal instead that image is abstracted
and tucked away into genetic information
and zooaspores and sperm alike are just
packets of that information swimming off
to new and different futures
foreign
so far we have seen the eggs the sperm
and the very messy process of getting
the two to meet and for our last video
we wanted to focus on what this is all
meant to be for baby tardigrades we'll
also find out the fate of our pregnant
water bear from the first episode and
see what lessons we learned in the
process
hello everyone and welcome back to the
second half of our tardigrade
reproduction spectacular in our last
episode we got a very close look though
I suppose all of our looks are pretty
close at the various biological
intimacies exchanged by tardigrades as
they mate
multiple males contended for the heart
or at least the unfertilized eggs of a
female tardigrade by poking endlessly at
her exuvia it was really quite dramatic
and if you haven't watched it yet you
should it's great there's poop
but now it is time for the thrilling
conclusion to all of that mating
the babies
this tardigrade has been lugging her
future Offspring in a sack made up of
her exuvia which is her shedded
exoskeleton like a spare room that's
been converted into a baby nursery the
same exuvia that started as the mother's
own cuticle before it became the site of
courtship has now undergone another
renovation to become a handy portable
egg Nursery
the waste of tardigrades deal with their
eggs may look different for different
species while this water bear carries
her exuvia at the end of her body some
species carry it more towards the front
some don't lay eggs in exuvia at all
while another species has been seen
depositing their eggs in the exuvia of
water fleas why our species has evolved
or chosen this method is unknown to us
maybe it allows her to provide them
protection or perhaps she could ensure
they hatch in the best possible location
this way we just don't know but we did
very much want to observe this mother to
be and so for three days we followed her
doing our best to also take good care of
her
and the biggest concern was making sure
she wouldn't get too dry so he had to
keep her away from the edges of the
slide to do this we used only the most
Advanced Techniques we poked her with
the fine hair from a brush to push her
towards the more watery regions of the
slide we even set an alarm to remind us
to add a drop of water to the slide
every four hours
yes even at night it's a lot of alarms
now you might be thinking aren't
tardigrades supposed to be the hardiest
creatures on Earth able to withstand
extreme conditions hypothetical
apocalypses and maybe even crash
Landings on the moon surely they do not
require this level of helicopter
parenting or I guess it's Grand
parenting well we do care a lot for all
of our microscopic organisms and so it
could be that this watery vigil is just
an abundance of caution on our part but
we've seen with our own eyes that no
matter how tough tardigrades may be the
microcosmos is tougher sometimes things
just happen and not in the way you might
hope
you might remember this tardigrade from
a previous episode we were pretty
excited about her because we could see
all of those eggs just ready to be
hatched but the mother was completely
still she hadn't moved at all which
would usually be worrisome but she
wasn't decomposing so we thought maybe
she was still alive just biting the time
until her eggs hatched and so while she
waited so did we gestation and
tardigrades can vary quite a bit not
just by species but with temperature and
just plain old chance it generally takes
a few days but it can take months
we kept her in a humidity chamber and
checked in to make sure the coverslip
wasn't crushing her
but the inactive tardigrade never became
active again eventually her body did
begin to decompose as did the eggs
inside her and so the tardigrade family
was not meant to be
we don't know what killed this
tardigrade but it's hard not to feel
responsible for the organisms we film
sure they're unaware of our existence
but they are in our care and like the
animals and humans we come to feel
connected to it's sad to be reminded
that endings can come for even the
mightiest creatures Among Us
even if they are also among the smallest
that's why when we later found the
impending tardigrade mother that started
this episode we took so much care to
keep her alive
it was nerve-wracking because we didn't
want to lose another brood hence the
four-hour alarms and the brush hair
so you might be able to imagine our
combined excitement and relief when
after four days of this intensive care
we saw a tardigrade cuticle that was no
longer full of eggs it was full of
eggshells and baby tardigrades
unfortunately it turned out that getting
footage of the actual hatching during
this moment was challenging the eggs
would roll around in the cuticle while
also being dragged by the mother but you
can see the baby tardigrades clawing
their way through the mass of eggs
eventually though the mother finally
completely shed her cuticle you can see
it here it almost looks like a
tardigrade ghost chasing behind her this
moment was particularly fortuitous for
us because as the tardigrade rid herself
of the exuvia that had housed her future
children
one unhatched egg came out as well
it's weird to look at this and realize
that in a few moments out will come a
tardigrade just an oval with some lines
in it a formed thing packed away that
arrow-shaped thing that's pumping away
is the tardigrades stylus a part of
their mouth that pokes out when it comes
time to eat and it helps the tardigrade
suction out the meatiness of the
microbes that it feeds on
but before they can get to eating the
stylets have an important task helping
the baby tardigrade get out of their
shell after two hours of struggling the
stylists of the tardigrade begin to move
more repetitively until finally it's
able to poke holes in the egg
those holes allow water into the egg
increasing the pressure inside until the
egg just pops
and out comes a little Moss Piglet and
with it a new generation is born adding
to a lineage of Mighty microscopic
animals stretching back hundreds of
millions of years
[Music]
thank you
if you heard a sigh just then it's a
sigh of relief and Joy from all of us at
the microcosmos team when we set out to
track and record a tardigrade birth we
didn't know that it would lead to both
heartbreak and excitement
but it's all worth it for this little
buddy among many we hope to see them all
again perhaps creating their own brood
but for now paddle away our little
friend the whole micro Cosmos awaits
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us
big shout out to the people on the
screen right now they are our patreon
patrons they're folks who think that
there should be a YouTube channel that
in a calm and Serene way discusses the
beautiful Splendor of the mystery of all
the tiny things that are all around us
all the time that for the vast majority
of human history we had no idea we're
even there so if you're happy that a
channel like ours exists it's people
like these who make that possible if you
want to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss you can check
out jam and germs on Instagram and if
you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
[Music]
foreign